i want to start tonight by talking to
you taking you back to the heat of the
presidential election it was the summer
of 2020 and the country was literally
falling apart
most of you were mandated to wear a mask
and stay inside but the wires they got
away with looting businesses and burning
down buildings curfews were simply just
annoyed
stores in major cities were boarded up
and democrats seized the moment claiming
all the violence on the streets was
caused by trump supporters not the
riders that did it in fact when one
protest broke out in kenosha joe biden
went there and gave a grand speech
blaming trump for all the division in
the country
the idea
that this president continues to try to
divide us give succour to the white
supremacist
talks about how
there's really good people on both sides
it legitimizes
it legitimizes the dark side
of human nature
and what it did though
it also exposed
what had not been paid enough attention
to
the underlying racism that is
institutionalized in the united states
we end up in a circumstance
like you had here in kenosha and have
here in kenosha
racism
but if democrats were really going to
sell the case that trump is a dangerous
man with loyal extremist followers they
needed a poster board
in her cal ridden house who cares if he
was a kid who cares about the
presumption of innocence it's a heated
election and trump has to go
the 17 year old accused of committing
those two murders was a trump support
it's a tragedy do you do you condemn
it's a tragedy do you condemn it it's a
tragedy it's uh it's a tragedy it's a
tragedy entire situation is a tragedy
you see the journalists that stand in
condemn it
it's a tragedy no no but condemn it
don't don't wait for the facts
ron johnson and people like you have
been dragged through the mud ever since
for simply
wanting justice to take its course
now that the election is over the case
has been made his way through the system
and it turns out the democrats and the
media couldn't have been more wrong
about ridden house
take the murder charge for example the
accusation was that he was part of a
militia and went to kenosha on that
august night to kill people
there was no other possibility he
couldn't have acted in self-defense
that wouldn't fit the narrative
but the argument fell apart this week on
monday one of the witnesses admitted he
pointed the gun at ridden house first
and then today there was this
ridden house struggling to tell the
events that happened that night watch
once i take that step back i look over
my shoulder and
mr rosenbaum
mr rosenbaum was now running
from
my right side
and
i was cornered from in front of me with
mr zaminski
and there were
wow
he had been steady the entire testimony
clear and concise
in that moment he broke down describing
him taking someone's life
so does that sound like a crazed killer
to you
but let's be honest the prosecution
knows he's not guilty today they got
desperate though and they tried every
dirty trick in the book they even tried
to use his own constitutional rights
against him
i was
astonished
when you began your examination by
commenting on the defendant's post
arrest silence that's basic law it's
been basic law in this country for 40
years 50 years i have no idea why you
would do something like that
so they managed to take off the judge
these are lawyers the prosecution knows
better
but they don't care they got a narrative
to push
so while we wait for a verdict tonight
with an 18 year old freedom on the line
we have to talk about accountability
regardless of the outcome there should
be consequences for these people who
manufactured this hoax it was clear
disinformation no it was misinformation
the people who colluded with the media
to to push this fake news did it all
just to win an election
i just hope it was worth it hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else